僕よく動画編集をするんですけども
江戸うるさ
どこからなってんだろうやばいよね夫があって本当にまずでこれちょっとさぁみんなに
伝えたいんだよね動画編集ってねパソコンにすごい負荷をかけるんですよ画像編集とか
インターネットとか
なんか動画見たりそういうのじゃなくて老兵すっていう作業って内容によってなんです
けどパソコンに一番負荷を与える作業なのかなと思っております今ゴリゴリの
めちゃくちゃ難しい品種して
んですけどもその辺集中阿蘇今どうなっているかと言うと
まあもてないんだけど暑くて聞こえますが音がいい
この風量やこの音これを感じてほしいです僕はいや本当に暑いず予算が目とかで使って
編集してるとほんとにパソコンあってもどうかしちゃうんじゃないか降ってるんです
けどもうこれ一応 mac から出てる最強のパソコンでそのパソコンをもってしても
ここだけ暑くねこれだけ暑いと微パソコンの上に卵をいたら目玉焼きが作れるんじゃ
ないかと思いましたよ
は処理しすぎてオーバーヒートしているパソコンで卵焼きが作れるかどうかを検証して
いきたいと思います結構画期的だと思いますけどこれができるようになれば動画編集し
ながら卵焼きが食べれるんでは絶対いける道んだよね乾杯低減早速史上最強のパソコン
で卵焼き作っていこうと思います
壊れますねさすがに猫のバス運行酒に行かない卵を置けるようにアルミホイルをのせ
ましょう
それやばい名前ダメだダメだすごいほら4ヤバイホラー
ジャガーちょっと四十路ねっぺ方へのでガムテープで押さえ込みますてこれ抑え込んで
いいのかな
入ってきましたこの上に卵を載せていこうと思いますや卵焼きできる温度なんだよ
いきます
あ
いい感じに乗ってますねばっつりで本来パソコンのある場所に食品とかってを言っちゃ
ダメなんで結構いうのはシビアな状況に置かれていますタブーで俺禁忌に触れてからね
個人的にスクランブルエッグ会ので膨らんブリックにしよっと
会場でこっからなんですけども百合根釣りを上げるためには僕がもっと激しい検証すれ
ばいいねもうちょい動画の編集頑張ってそこに負荷かけて熱暴走
若させていきたいと思いますめちゃくちゃパソコンがクラッシュ兵種してやったなぁ
[音楽]
どうすったパソコンはなんか音が小さくなったことがこれ多分多分に卵が多すぎるんだ
なもっと薄くしないと卵焼きができないからちょっと水ますわ
大
placebo ちょっと薄めてみたんでこれだと多分もっと作りやすい気がします
です
よしがんばろ
浮いて来てねひっくり返るんだけどメディアは本トップはではスッキはついなん
余ってしっくりぶりで暑いんだけどちょっと待ったパソコンが悲鳴をあげてる気がする
んだからもうちょい頑張ってくれれば行ける気が住んであるんですけどがんばるぞ
あっつまず奴へ消えちゃったなんかすごくがおかしくなってきた圧痛
もうほんと触れたエレベーターアーティストは今
もう一本で頑張ってくれああ
あもうやばいポンドダメっすよねー
[音楽]
貼ってやったかないったんですまずあない雑談
ちょっと待って待って待って待って待ったはいという気で少し作成変更です mac
pro が厚いというかこの mac pro の周りの子の壁で空文化ついてること
が築いたんでこれ食べてパソコンとよる直でここでおいた方が絶対さのボヤキができる
と思うんですよねここなら卵焼きができるかなと思いました
ちょっと鼻を頑張っ
いきたいとおもいます今更に編集して超厚くしてやるんで
この温度なら掃除に行ってる気がしますどんな固まれ
[音楽]
ん
ダメ実は若干白くなってちょっといけると思ったんですけどねちょっともう ikea
食べるんですけどいやちょっと時間においてみましょう
今まで一番ついぞいますで市松江これで目立ったのは切られますは
いきます
[音楽]
どうだどう結構ビビリくらいゴリッゴリ捺印ですけど
ごめんマリー
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
バッハ